good morning John I'm sorry about your
face I wanted to make a video for you to
make you feel better and I didn't know
which kind to make so I asked Twitter if
I should do a rant video or a joke video
and man was it overwhelmingly in favor
of rants why do you need to see me get
angry instead of be funny it's the
negative cognitive bias so prevalent in
our society and in our brains that we
can't just have a good time so that was
my first one let's talk about driving
for a second if you text while you're
driving and you say well it's okay
because I'm really good at it I'm really
careful what you're really saying is
well I haven't killed anyone yet
don't don't stop just don't stop
Blee then what's happening this also
goes for if you're waiting at a light
especially if you're the first in line
and you're looking at your text messages
and the light screen now in this
situation I will honk at you this is not
an excuse to get angry at me because you
were the one not driving at a green
light I apologize for being so rude to
you I guess I should have just sat there
forever literally speaking of people who
are incapable of not looking at their
phones every two seconds if that's you
that's fine but don't go to movies just
never do it there's other ways to be
entertained than watching a movie while
checking Facebook with you're brighter
than the Sun self Oh topic change people
who mock others for their choice of
major in school especially because it's
almost always science people like myself
going after humanities people start to
bring this up but interacting with and
creating for other humans is one of the
only things that computers are not
getting really really good at really
fast so humanities jobs are actually
pretty safe from being automated away so
maybe don't be so entitled also people
who mock others for using words like Bay
or boo or slay look language is fluid
and subcultures define themselves by
using slang terms you do that too what
you're really saying when you complain
about other people's slang words is my
subcultures better than yours which of
course you do believe we all believe
that it's getting up on your soapbox and
shouting about it makes you look
pretentious and patronizing so yeah if
your definition of rant is just
complaining about people who happen to
be different from you you're a big bag
of farts you're on a website are you
thinking about requiring the users of
that website to do something do not ask
them if they would like to do that thing
if you're going to require it because if
I'm asked and I click no I don't want to
do that and then the website says okay
we'll ask again later
that's not
good user experience all cars have
screens in them now I don't have a car
like this but all the new ones do is
what I've noticed instead of using the
absolutely free and wonderful Android
operating system car companies have
insisted on creating their own operating
systems and software the software is
awful congratulations on making a brand
new car feel like a first generation
iPhone software is so on responses you
hit a button and then it's like oh let
me think about that for a second and
then you're like did you register that I
hit the button so yeah hit it a few more
times as the software is like oh let me
register all of those punches in
sequence on multiple screens as we go
through even though you couldn't see
these things when you were hitting the
button and suddenly you've reached some
obscure place inside of the software
you've lowered your dash lights in a way
that you'll never be able to figure out
how to undo hey if somebody's like
please don't use that word in that way
it makes me feel bad about myself how
about you don't get all defensive and
start defending your set just don't use
that word in that way because it makes
them feel bad about themselves so if
you've ever talked about leveraging
online influencers to connect with
digital natives through mobile stackable
content you're fired
just go to your desk get your stuff
leave I went to school for like 85 years
and no one ever taught me how to do my
taxes what's that why wouldn't you the
school's paid for by the government and
they want you to pay taxes why wouldn't
they teach you that also I know how to
do long division why why do I know how
to solve a quadratic equation without
knowing what a quadratic equation is
well maybe that should've been the time
when you were teaching me how to do my
taxes also cursive writing do they still
do that because all I was so bad at it
and I spent so much of my life learning
how to do this thing that I've never
done and finally my final round of this
rant video cable news hmm thanks for
watching John I hope you enjoyed and
I'll see you on Tuesday you can watch my
first rant video over there also the
draft love design is back except with
better colors it's shiny and we got new
tank tops for summer